brett hart is a wrestler his brother
owen hart recently died in a horrible
accident during a wwf event one of these
uh flying stunts is that's just
something that's sort of uh one of those
fluke things where
i don't know just everything goes wrong
that night who the hell knows i i don't
know who knows i think what it comes
down to is um
you know it's it's one of those it's
like an accident and evidently your
brother was a great guy from everyone
any of the wrestlers i've had on this
show they just talk about him in
in a glowing way they feel that he was
just a down-to-earth guy not carried
away with the business uh not carried
away with his fame and success
and was a down-to-earth nice guy to hang
with on the wrestling circuit yeah he
was
i can't think of a better guy he was
such a great guy on the road he was and
he was a great family guy right
and he was
had an unbelievable sense of humor he
was so funny to be around all time so it
wasn't he was never one of those kind of
guys that you didn't real you know he
didn't
look forward to having him around he
always liked being around he was the
best practical joker i ever met i mean
he was just such a funny guy all the
time and he was very he had a very
subtle
you know kind of approach to you know
pulling pranks and stuff for you know
when no one ever knew he set it up kind
of thing and then you'd see you know
you'd be pulling out of a gas station
and two guys would be fighting kind of
thing right right he's a fun guy to hang
with he was a master yes yeah and it's
particularly sad when it's a good guy
like that and you and your brother were
close growing up and your father i mean
your father was an intense
not only wrestling fan but was he a
wrestler himself yeah he was a wrestler
and then he
basically um became a promoter which
means he sort of used to run the
wrestling out in western canada did you
not like him was he one of those dads
that pressured you into wrestling and
forced you uh did he
because it sounds like you had a violent
family that like you had to like you had
to fight your sisters and stuff yeah it
was it was a kind of a dog-eat-dog world
kind of household you know did your dad
set it up that way there's still a
wrestling area isn't there
yeah oh yeah there's a little room they
call the dungeon which still you know it
still works but uh but i don't i don't
understand growing up like your dad's
into wrestling so therefore all of his
kids have to fight each other
well no it wasn't like that it was like
when you have 12 kids so that's a lot of
kids it's like a little hot that's like
a hotel or at least it's it's something
to keep them busy in activity if they
are fighting all the time then perhaps
they can wear them out they'll go to bed
dinner time most of the time so we're
kind of all stuck in the house your
father was a violent man i mean angry
man no but uh very very uh well he could
have a short fuse because i read
something where somebody said that uh
your dad would like there was some
delivery guy or something he didn't like
it he put him in a wrestling hold for
hours like a chokehold or something he
likes to put people to sleep yeah
there's a funny story but my dad's
actually a really uh compassionate guy
right you had to have to catch him on
the right day but
he there was a time when i was a kid
when uh uh it was about two or three in
the morning because somebody tried to
steal my dad lived out further out in
the city than um then like he lived a
few miles out of town yeah and uh yes
someone tried to steal his car he had
left the keys in it in the wintertime i
guess the guy got stuck in the driveway
and my dad went out to thought it was
one of my brothers you know and he went
out to
help this poor soul and he instead
dragged him into the house i just
remembered pots and pans smashing all
over the place
my dad tortured him for hours and hours
and hours in the kitchen of the house
but you imagine you're trying to steal a
car
and the guy's like a professional
wrestler he catches you rather than
calling the police he just takes you
into the kitchen yeah the guy has a
place called the dungeon it wrestles you
and then like puts you in like a sleeper
hold for hours i mean you'd rather go to
the police wouldn't you yeah it was i
was scared to death i thought it was one
of my brothers and then i found out
after that it wasn't
but he never phoned the police he called
this guy's parents up and they picked no
kidding yeah so in a lot of ways i
always thought it was that was cool
pretty cool oh that's very cool not
stealing your cars anything
i know i wouldn't be doing that that is
very cool
you